anton claireaux quels sont les enjeux de
la présence turque
aujourd'hui à moscou donc oui ce pourait
de naître une journée décisive pour
l'avenir de la libye après la rencontre
entre vladimir poutine et son homologue
turc recep tayyip erdogan en milieu de
semaine dernière rencontre lors de
laquelle ils ont réclamé et obtenu un
cessez le feu en libye au tour
maintenant de leurs ministres respectifs
des affaires étrangères et de la défense
de se réunir aujourd'hui à moscou afin
de définir les contours et les modalités
de ce cessez le feu d'autant que vous
l'avez dit devrait être également
présents les deux principaux
protagonistes du conflit en libye à
savoir le chef du gouvernement d'union
nationale fayez elle sa rage ainsi que
son rival l'homme fort de l'est libyen
le maréchal rallye phare haftar tous les
ingrédients semblent donc réunies pour
des discussions productives et si celle
ci aboutisse à une relance du processus
politique
en tout cas la russie a été très active
ces derniers jours sur ce dossier les
bien venir poutine a multiplié les
contacts il a parlé par téléphone aux
dirigeants de l'egypte du qatar des
émirats arabes unis de l'italie ou
encore de la france pas plus tard
qu'hier soir donc lors d'une
conversation téléphonique avec emmanuel
macron sans oublier dont vous l'avez
mentionné la réception de la chancelière
allemande angela merkel au kremlin il ya
tout juste deux jours
merci antoine frérot en direct de moscou
en russie